counterattacked against the black queen
and uh yeah if these trades happen if
both the queens disappear magnus is
simply going to be a couple of pawns up
magnus nodding his head there slightly
as well he thinks he's got this one
under control it does look that way so
knight takes knight white's queen under
fire temporarily black is a piece up but
white has a selection of uh pieces to
take to recapture white for example can
use his knight and take that black
knight in the middle still attacking and
counter-attacking against the black
queen yeah
he can definitely do that and he's done
it and after bishop chase queen knight
takes queen check
my taste night's forced
yep so right now black's a piece up but
now no longer and look everything's
getting hovered off all the captures
white gives a nasty check that might
have been a surprise from mama jarv look
at majora's face it was a surprise he
resigns magnus takes the win wow and
look at that reaction from magnus
carlsen i wasn't sure if he was digging
the music or digging the victory he is
the winner of this match